i am a true california girl
i am i love it here for so many reasons
but mostly because this is a place
that is a year-round destination with so
many amazing outdoor events we actually
teamed up with visit california to drop
in on an event the other night take a
look
we are about to crash a movie screening
that's right because in california the
weather is so beautiful that you can sit
under the twinkling stars and the
gorgeous city lights and actually watch
a movie outside
but what you don't know is that the
movie is actually 50 first date so i'm
gonna go and surprise some people let's
see how this goes
hi everybody
hi
um
my name is drew barrymore
and um i wanted to come and personally
present this movie to you tonight it
just seemed like a wonderful opportunity
on this gorgeous california night
in this warm weather
to be able to enjoy a movie that is
happy and joyful and hopeful and
ironically really talks about the
challenges we face in life i think this
is why i've always wanted to make films
like a 50 first dates
so it's a pleasure to have gotten to do
movies that i think do put you in a good
mood and you know if anyone has a
question about the movie i was there and
i could answer any fun trivia or facts i
see a hand raised
hi drew
hello i've been a big fan my whole life
so thank you for your work and all that
you've done for making us happier
i really appreciate it um i guess i was
wondering in context of this movie if
there's ever been a day in your life
that you wanted to relive over and over
again gosh that's such a good question
it would definitely be a day with my
daughters
until i met them life was just you know
fun and dandy but when i met them like
everything changed so any day where the
three of us are there is the day i want
to stay in permanently
thank you for asking me that question um
i saw you raised your hand oh hi i love
you i love your show i love you i
literally just got here from toronto
today so this is a really interesting
surprise welcome to california thank you
um so i know that you film your show in
new york so what's the reason that
you're here
so one of the things that we wanted to
do with season two of the show because
season one we weren't able to travel
anywhere and i always saw this show as
something we would take on the road
i'm from california i now live in new
york and it's a really fun chapter we're
not gonna lie but these are my roots i
love california
and
nights like this and to see a skyline
and greenery
is something that i miss so much
there really is no place like california
it's weird that you can be at an ocean a
mountain a desert and a forest all
within 30 minutes this is a very magical
state so i just felt like kicking the
season two off um here do you want to
ask one last question i see a raised
hand right there thank you for taking
the time to answer some questions my mom
came to she's in town we are huge fans
of yours ever after is our all-time
favorite movie as well as never been
kissed
so i just wanted to know if you ever had
a favorite movie
that you enjoyed working on you just
named the two movies that really changed
my life and charlie's angels too
when it comes to
filmmaking
i wanted feelings at the end of these
films and forever after i wanted people
to feel like i am in control of my own
destiny i wanted for 50 first dates for
people to have faith and believe in the
goodness of people and love and
charlie's angels
yeah i wanted to drive a stick shift and
get into fourth gear
maybe fifth
but tonight i hope you let everything
fall away for a moment
and watch something that
i promise you we all made for you to
feel good so thank you for letting me
invade your space tonight
and may you have such a beautiful
wonderful rest of your evening thank you
that was so much fun i really do love
surprising people i love when people do
it to me and i've actually totally
gotten gotten into doing it to people so
that was really fun and um
you kind of
never know what you're gonna get
during a night out in california you
might even bump into me i'm just saying
[Music]